flat open terrain on Ukraine's Southern
front means it's safer to move under the
cover of Darkness to avoid being
detected a Ukrainian reconnaissance
Soldier shows us a network of what used
to be Russian
trenches no well-lit paths only markers
to warn of landmines just Paces
away the forest line where we are right
now was the enemy's position we walk a
precise path that we had to make
ourselves Russ put improvised traps on
top of anti-tank mines and if they
detonate he stops himself at least two
men were killed taking these trenches
just stay on the path he says
for this is a war of artillery now both
sides fighting from fixed
positions this unit is covering
Ukrainian infantry in another set of
trenches up ahead after that our Russian
positions
it could be a war fought a century ago
until the sound of modern military
equipment brings you
back drone a drone taras says confused
about where it is who it is before
carrying on we're at the exact place
where Ukrainian forces are trying to
drive a wedge into Russian lines there's
Russian positions on two sides of the
units based here and whenever they take
over these former Russian trenches one
of the biggest problems posed to the
Troops here are landmines unexploded
ordinance improvised traps and whenever
they try to move forward they see the
Russians have moved back to other layers
of trenches and that is what is now
slowing down the counter offensive in
areas like this on the southern
front much needed ammunition arrives
Seri a carpenter before the war says
there is only one thing Frontline
soldiers need
more
what we want most is to go home to go
home to see the family apart from that
we have everything we need we can fight
we want to get rid of them and go
home the Russians are adjusting fire he
says telling everyone to take
cover the job of holding positions and
pushing forward is a lot tougher than it
looks where ukrainians fire
mortars and Russians respond with 500 kg
laser guided aerial
bombs zann basravi Al jazer near roboty
in Ukraine's Zaria
region make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer